Oh nice!
you shoulda led with that bro yeah not
bad
i love it
it's perfect
sounds like we need to call pest control
what was that
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video all about the
supergirl cancellation i'll explain
what's going on with the dc tv shows why
they decided to end the show
especially because of what's going on
with the justice league snyder cut in
the big
budget dc hbo shows that warner brothers
is developing
separately that are not connected to the
cw dc tv shows
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know which big dc
hbo show you're most excited to see so
just starting with the big stuff first
number five this past week warner
brothers tv
and the producers of supergirl including
melissa announced that they were ending
the show after the upcoming season six
that they were getting ready to start
filming this month
it was a bit of a surprise given how
much time they'd spent hyping her
character up during crisis on infinite
earths with the flash in that ending
scene they literally put her front and
center in this lineup with superman in
the background even though he's a much
bigger character
here's the official statement that
deadline variety all the hollywood
trades are reporting
so it says between the delays talking
about virus delays and super girls
downward ratings trajectory i hear that
the producers the studio in the network
in melissa
came to a decision that it was better to
end the show with a longer
final season that means more than the
typical 20 episodes
the creative team has started developing
story lines for the final 20 episodes
the order is expected to be longer than
most broadcast series this coming season
including the cw scripted shows which
will be launching
in january and beyond none of the cw dc
tv shows like the flash or the new
superman tv show will be premiering till
january or a little bit later
as it keeps adding new series every
season the cw has also been retiring
veterans it ended three established
series in each of the last two seasons
including arrow supernatural
the 100 this past season the network
which traditionally gives its
long-running series a proper farewell by
announcing their final seasons ahead of
time will likely reveal
more shows coming to an end after the
upcoming season
in the coming weeks that means they also
might be canceling some of the other dc
shows coming pretty soon i'll address
that in a second
but number four something that they
don't mention in all the articles that
are being posted
is the fact that melissa just had a baby
recently
and her desire to spend more time at
home with the baby also played a factor
in canceling supergirl but here's the
thing with that they knew that baby was
coming a while ago that wasn't a brand
new surprise thing that just happened
out of nowhere
and earlier this year they'd already
been talking about next year's crossover
after
crisis on infinite earth how did they
follow that up they'd been talking about
more minor crossovers with other dc tv
shows like the flash
even star girl crossovers which is now
fully a cw dc tv show as of season 2.
they literally bought that show from the
dc universe and they own it now
there was even a big crisis on infinite
earth's dc fandome panel where they were
supposed to release a bunch of deleted
scenes from crisis
but for whatever reason there was some
issue that prevented them from doing
that
i don't know which scenes they were
going to release but i've already done
some deleted scene videos for crisis on
infinite earths like there was a michael
keaton batman deleted scene that they
had developed but never wound up making
it to screen
but obviously things are not well in the
cw dc tv universe
just a little while ago they announced
that ruby rose was quitting the batwoman
show they recast the role
so it just seems like the cw in dc tv
universe the arrowverse is crumbling
since arrow ended now super girls ending
in some of the other shows as they say
in that big news announcement are also
getting ready to end
as you probably guessed legends of
tomorrow in black lightning are the two
other shows that are on the chopping
block after next season
there's a rating slowly in decline and
there's a lot of other stuff going on at
warner brothers behind the scenes that
i'll talk about in a second too
with the big budget hbo stuff number
three though the other major reason
that's not listed in a lot of these
articles
is that there's a new superman tv show
with tyler heckler and superman starting
next season
they'll be filming later this year and
new episodes will obviously start
filming next year alongside the flash
season seven
this is the upcoming broadcast schedule
they announced so you can see they're
already hyping up superman in the flash
together
grant gustin said that he hopes that
they get to do a ton of superman flash
crossovers the episode's schedule is a
little wonky though just because of the
virus delays
the shows would normally be doing 20 to
22 episodes per season but i think
some of the shows will be doing a little
bit less than that just because of the
scheduling issues
the new superman series is kind of like
a sequel series to smallville a
spiritual successor it's an older
version of superman and lois lane moving
back to smallville to raise their twin
superboy sons after having lived in
metropolis for many years
his version of superman has been
superman for a good long while
smallville ended the finale right as he
was officially taking the mantle and
started to wear the costume
so you have to imagine what smallville
would have been like as a show
15 years later after they'd have kids
and raise them they're getting a little
bit weird with the crisis on infinite
earth's retcons to their backstories in
that final episode they started crisis
with baby john ken
but after crisis the new changes are
that they have twin boys and they're
both teenagers who are fraternal twins
you can also kind of see what they're
doing creatively with a supergirl tv
show because the superman show has
started taking some of the characters
from supergirl and recasting them with
new actors
so you'll see a lot of the same
characters show up it'll just be
different
actors playing those roles you could
chalk it up to crisis on infinite earth
you could call it whatever you want
soft retcons it just seems like they're
rewriting a little bit of supergirl
history
for this superman tv show number two
also they haven't talked about it since
the supergirl cancellation announcement
but the idea now is that melissa in some
of the mains from the supergirl tv show
like martian manhunter
will just start guest starring on the
superman tv show every season
and come back for future big crossovers
you can make all the jokes you want to
about that justice league scene at the
end of crisis on infinite earth because
half of the people at that table
probably won't be around in another year
or so but i think they're going to keep
a lot of the justice league stuff they
do
on the dc tv universe to the big
crossovers
particularly because they have a big hbo
series coming with justice league in the
title actually technically two if you
include the snyder cut
but the supergirl character isn't really
going anywhere you just won't see her
every single week after next season is
over and they'll just use the next
season of that show to explain what
she's going to be doing
between big future cameo appearances on
other shows
they also said that next year's
crossover is supposed to be mainly a
superman centric event and originally
they had talked about doing a superman
batman style smaller crossover
that would have featured batwoman but i
don't know if that's changed because of
what happened with ruby rose leaving
that show and then recasting
in number one the obvious elephant in
the room that i haven't talked about yet
is
as the dc tv shows are all starting to
end or getting close to ending the flash
is still going to go on for a little bit
longer
warner brothers and a t have started to
refocus their attention
on mostly developing the big budget hbo
dc shows based on all the dc movies like
the batman hbo series they just
announced
the green lantern series justice league
dark even the new constantine series
that they're talking about doing
is going to be an hbo show you have
titan season 3
doom patrol season 3 all the dc universe
stuff
those are hbo shows starting next season
so it's pretty clear that the dc movies
are replacing
the tv shows as the new tv and how does
the cw
compete with 150 million dollar budget
for a tv show that only does eight
episodes
there was even a quote from an at t
executive
saying that their dc hbo shows would
have the highest level of production
quality
that kind of felt like a sick burn on
the cw dc tv shows like do those not
have the highest level of production
quality
so there's just no way that the cw can
compete with what's going on in the dc
hbo series if you don't know what's
going on with some of those the batman
hbo show is going to be based on robert
pattinson's new batman movies
matt reeves developed it personally and
it's going to be a batman year one show
so i'll explain more about that
of course i'll be doing episode videos
for all that stuff you've been asking
for a batman hbo series for years now
they're finally giving it to you it
seemed like a no-brainer
in the constantine hbo show that they
were talking about is coming from jj
abrams people out of the justice league
dark hbo series that they're also doing
there was some talk about them trying to
bring back keanu reeves as constantine
for a new project
because during the flash movie panel
they had some footage from his movie
when they were talking about connecting
everything using the multiverse in
flashpoint
as for tom welling coming back and guest
starring on the new superman tv show
because they were going to be set during
smallville and they're going to be using
a lot of the same
looking sets as the smallville tv show
did i think that just depends on whether
or not he wants to come back i think
they would have him anytime he wanted to
come back
but everyone click here for the new
superman trailer for that superman tv
show and click here for my new justice
league snyder cut batman scenes and
trailer footage
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!